الدفع في المطاعم بنظام التعرف على الوجه
مشهد بات مالوفا في الصين مع انتشار
استخدام التكنولوجيا المتقدمه في مناحي
حياتك غير ان القلق الامريكي من الاستخدام
الصيني لمثل هذه التقنيات يكمن في مجال
اخر الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم
يعد عام 2016 تاريخا مفصليا في تطور
الذكاء الاصطناعي حين هزم كمبيوتر شركه
جوجل الامريكي بطل العالم في لعبه الصينيه
ولان عدد الخطوات المحتمله في هذه اللعبه
التي تشبه الشطرنج غير محدود فان تحفيظ
الكمبيوتر خطوات مسبقا امر محال لكن من
خلال تقنيه التعلم المتعمق امتلك
الكمبيوتر ذكاء اصطناعيا يمكنه من التعلم
الذاتي وابتداع خطوات لم يفكر فيها
الانسان
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم هو ان تكون
الاله قادره على تعليم نفسها تماما كما
نفعل نحن البشر وذلك يعتمد على مجموعه
كبيره من البيانات والمعلومات المدخله
وعليه نستطيع القول ان هذا المستوى من
التعلم الالي يمكن ان يتفوق على الذكاء
البشري لعل الصين ادركت حين هزمها
الكمبيوتر الامريكي في لعبتها التي تعود
الى اكثر من
2500 سنه ان عليها اللحاقه بركب تطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم بل ان تسعى الى
ان تصبح رائده في هذا المجال بحلول عام
2030 تبلغ قيمه الاستثمار في سوق الذكاء
الصناعي الصيني اكثر من 23 مليار دولار
ومن المتوقع حسب مختصين ان يتجاوز الرقم
250 مليارا بحلول عام 2030 كما حصلت
الشركه الناشئه في مجال الذكاء الصناعي
على دعم حكومي بلغ 17 مليار دولار العام
الماضي وتعتبر شركه بايتو احدى الشركه
الرائده في هذا المجال
بنحو 46 الف موظف تستحوذ بيته على سوق
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم في الصين وتمتلك
محرك البحث الاول في البلاد منذ انشائها
عام 2000 خلال العقدين الاخيرين طورت
بيدوس 57 تطبيقا يسمح لها بالوصول الى
بيانات نحو مليار مستخدم للانترنت في
الصين اضافه الى تصنيع السيارات ذاتيه
القياده واشباه الموصلات لتصبح المنافس
الاول لشركات امريكيه مثل تسلا
يلقى تطوير الذكي للصناعي المتقدم دعما
ضخما لاهميته في صناعه السيارات الذكيه
ومجال الطاقه والكهرباء كما اننا ننتج
الجيل الثاني من الرقائق الالكترونيه التي
تستخدم في تشغيل السيارات ذاتيه القياده
ونظرا الى غياب القوانين الصارمه بشان
الخصوصيه يعد الوصول الى كميه هائله من
البيانات احد العوامل التي تمنح الصين
ميزه تنفسيه كبيره في سوق الذكاء الصناعي
اما العامل الثاني فيتمثل في تطوير رقائق
الكترونيه قادره على تحليل ملايين
البيانات بسرعه فائقه وهي اشباه الموصلات
القادره على القيام بثلاثمائه عمليه في
الثانيه والتي حضرت الولايات المتحده
بيعها للشركات الصينيه خشيت استخدامها في
التكنولوجيا العسكريه كالتعرف على الصوت
والوجه والتجسس
اعتقد ان الصين تملك بدائل بعض العقوبات
الامريكيه ضد شركات مثل هواوي وزي تي اي
التي تهدف الى قطع امدادات احدث الرقائق
الالكترونيه في الصناعات الاستهلاكيه
والعسكريه لكن الصين قادره على تطويرها
ولديها اكبر عدد من خريج الهندسه
التكنولوجيه والرياضيات
المواجهه التكنولوجيه بين الصين والولايات
المتحده مفتوحه في ساحه عده ومنها المجال
الطبي لكن اهم هذه الساحات واخطرها هي
المجال العسكري وفي هذا السياق حددت الصين
هدفا لبناء جيش متطور تكنولوجيا عام 2027
تكون اولويته التفوق على الولايات المتحده
شيماء شووي الجزيره